All right, just waiting for Twitch to
tell me that the stream is running.
Looks like we're live.
Great.
It's our last lecture. Welcome to the
end of week 10.
Wow, you made it.
Congratulations.
You know, a few minutes ago I was on
Twitter
and I asked uh
what should I tell my undergrads, most
of whom are graduating seniors,
using the such what such a platform as I
have, right, in these last few minutes
that I have with you?
And uh of course they said wrong answers
only.
So, and I got lots of funny responses
like don't wear sunscreen.
And uh all distributed systems problems
can be solved by suitable application of
blockchain technologies.
So,
whatever you do,
uh please take the opposite of that
advice.
All right, folks. So, today the I don't
have any new material uh to share with
you. I just have a couple of
announcements to make and then we can
use the rest of the time for answering
questions that you might have. So,
whatever those questions might be.
So, if you do have questions, please
share them in the lecture chat.
And if nobody has questions, then we'll
end early and give you a little bit more
time to work on the last assignment.
So, um announcements that I have
uh
first of all, um I want to make sure
that everybody knows about our research
group here at UCSC. So, uh, I, along
with a group of other students and
faculty,
am part of this loosely organized
federation that we call the languages
systems and data lab or the LSD lab for
short.
And the goal of this is to create a
community where people who are
interested in all of these different
research topics, whether it's
systems, distributed systems, operating
systems,
database systems, data management
systems, and programming languages. All
of these things can intermingle and
benefit from one one another. So, as
some of you know, my background is in
programming languages. That's what I
studied when I was in grad school.
And then I moved into this area of
distributed systems only later. So,
I believe that there's a lot to be
gained from people who are working on
different topics talking to one another.
And I think that I missed out when I was
in grad school by kind of singularly
focusing on one topic to the exclusion
of others.
So, what I'm interested in these days is
bringing together
ideas from programming languages
research and ideas from distributed
systems research. I like to tell people
that I'm interested in
using programming languages solutions to
solve distributed systems problems, and
that's what my students and I work on.
In particular, I'm interested in using
programming languages techniques to
formally verify that distributed systems
behave the way that they should.
And so, if that's something that you're
interested in, then maybe you should
take a look at what we're doing in the
LSD lab.
I also want to specifically advertise
that we have a talk tomorrow.
Uh, so every Friday during the the
regular quarter, uh have uh our our talk
series, the Languages Systems and Data
Seminar, and uh on
uh this week uh we have we are lucky to
have a talk from uh Renisha Ware, who
will be visiting us from CMU.
And her talk is going to be called
Battle for Bandwidth: Evaluating
Congestion Control Deployability for the
Internet. So, this will be a cool talk
for people who are interested in things
like networking. And so, please come
join us tomorrow, and if you want to
know the details, um go to lsd.ucsc.edu.
Uh and you can learn more about that.
I also want to share with you a couple
of other things, uh and I'll post the
links to these uh on Zulip. So,
in my first couple of years here at
UCSC, I was lucky enough to get to teach
some uh graduate courses that are
relevant to the kind of research that I
do. So, in my first quarter here at
UCSC, in fall 2018, I taught a course
called Languages and Abstractions for
Distributed Programming.
And the web page uh here is still up,
and there's a
uh
reading list of interesting papers that
are kind of in this uh topic area,
um a lot of which have to do with things
that we have been talking about uh all
quarter in this course.
Uh also, my students and I wrote a blog.
So,
there's a series of blog posts here that
were all written and edited by my
students and me.
And so,
I've been finding as students come to
office hours and they ask me questions
about stuff that often I find myself
referring to these blog posts that were
written by my grad students and me uh
3 years ago now. So, there could be a
lot of stuff in here that's of interest
to a lot of you if you take a look. Um
so, I encourage you to check it out, and
I'll I'll share that link in the chat.
Um
So, that was what I did uh in fall 2018.
Uh then in um
uh
fall 2019,
I was lucky enough to get to teach
another graduate special topics course.
And that one was on a totally different
topic, uh
which is uh SMT solver and solving and
solver-aided systems. So,
I'll talk about how this What does this
have to do with distributed systems?
Well,
as somebody who's interested in
programming languages and verification,
I'm interested in things like
how do we build high-powered
verification technologies that can help
us reason about distributed systems?
As we've seen, one of the challenges in
reasoning about distributed systems is
that there's this huge space of
possibilities that can happen, right?
There's a lot of orders in which
messages could get delivered. There's uh
a lot of combinations of machines that
could fail or not fail, right? And the
bigger the system gets, the bigger the
the state space of possibilities of
things that could go wrong.
Well, when you're trying to reason about
a big state space, it helps to have some
mechanized tools that are good at that
sort of thing. And so, SMT solvers are
tools that can, if used well, help us
reason about these sorts of systems and
make sure that we've kind of covered all
the bases in knowing whether there's a
bug, right?
So, how can this be useful to us when
we're building distributed systems?
Well, if you could have something like,
let's say, a type system in a
programming language that's hooked up to
the power of an SMT solver, then that
type system can let you express
really, really rich properties of
programs, including things like
are messages getting delivered in causal
order, which is something that we've
talked about this quarter. So, that is
in fact something that my students and I
are working on right now. In order to
work on that, we had to study SMT
solvers and understand how they work.
So, this course is all about um
about SMT solving and
there's some lecture notes here that you
can check out if that's interesting to
you that I wrote. Um and then there's a
whole bunch of papers that have to do
with applications of SMT solving, not
just to distributed systems, but to all
kinds of other problems as well. Um like
test generation
or um
uh
synthesizing programs, program
synthesis. Um so, all this stuff is is
uh is really really cool and I think in
many many ways it's the future of
of programming languages research.
And I'd love to talk to you more about
it if you're interested.
Okay. So, that's it for that stuff.
Um
now I want to
turn it over to you. So,
what questions do you have for me if
any? And if you don't have any, then you
know, we'll end early today. Uh
but uh but I want to try to answer your
questions in advance of the final and
you know, that you can either ask me
stuff about the course material or about
uh anything at all, really.
So, let's open the floor to questions.
I guess I can first answer a couple of
um
logistical questions that somebody
asked. So, um
uh
in office hours I was asked whether
tutoring sessions would still be going
on next week. So,
I I wouldn't count on it.
Uh I don't think the course staff
is expected to still hold their tutoring
sessions. Some of them might still
choose to,
and they might still be listed on the
calendar in Canvas, but
I wouldn't necessarily trust that
information. So, um
if you still want to attend a a tutoring
session uh next week, I would suggest
that you confirm with that person that
it's actually happening. Um
but there's no expectation from me that
the the tutors are going to keep doing
their their tutoring sessions during
finals week. They might, but um but it's
not guaranteed.
Oh, another question in chat. My
favorite IDE and or text editor.
So,
I am an Emacs user.
I do not impose my views on anyone else.
So, actually right now one of my grad
students is an Emacs user and one is a
Vim user. And so, they still manage to
collaborate somehow.
Um but I personally am an I'm an Emacs
user mostly out of habit. When I was in
undergrad,
uh XEmacs was the popular choice.
And so, that's what I learned how to
use.
And um
in fact, so when I when I first started
undergrad, I didn't really know how to
use any sophisticated text editor. And
then um
I was embarrassed one day because uh I
had to do a presentation in front of the
class,
and I was using Gedit, which was the
crummy
uh default text editor on the the Linux
distribution that we were using at the
time. And so,
I was really embarrassed that I was
using my bad text editor in front of
everybody. And so, I thought I had
better learn how to use a good text
editor, and that's what kind of shamed
me into learning uh Emacs.
And it stuck. So, here we are uh 15
years later and I'm still an Emacs user.
Um
Emacs is not perfect, but that but it
has a lot going for it and it's very
extremely customizable. So, you can make
it do just about anything that you want.
Okay, next question. Favorite
programming language, right? Yeah, okay.
Well, and what I would recommend for
this class? Well, those are kind of
different questions. So,
when it comes to what programming
language one should use to do a group
project,
that largely depends on the group,
right?
So,
and in general, I would say that the
advantages and disadvantages of
different languages
are
I mean, okay, some yeah, sure. I have
preferences about programming languages,
but
the most important factor is
what will help your group work well
together, right? And that's going to
depend a lot on what the group knows and
you know, what the group is comfortable
with. So,
you know, the advice that Peter Norvig
gives to people who want to, you know,
choose what language to learn as their
first programming language, his advice
is actually use whatever your friends
are using.
And I think that's actually pretty good
advice because the most important thing
is to have a community where you can
talk to other people and get help and
you know,
have joys and and suffering together,
right? So, um
I
I I it's I hesitate to say oh, any given
programming language is the best.
For me personally, though, I'll I'll say
some programming languages that I like a
lot. Um I'm a big fan of Rust.
Um I was lucky enough to get to work on
Rust in the early days. I am not a
particularly good Rust programmer
because Rust has changed a lot since
then. Uh so the Rust that I knew was
like Rust 0.3, and Rust has evolved a
lot since then, and it's become a whole
ecosystem.
But um
a lot of things about the design of Rust
uh
are great. Um
these days for research, I'm using
Haskell, but I'm not a particularly good
Haskell programmer either. And I'm using
Haskell because it's the best platform
to do the kind of work that I want to do
on things like SMT powered type systems,
that sort of thing. So it's not It's not
so much that I'm a die-hard Haskell
programmer, it's just that that's where
the tools are available to do the kind
of work I want to do. And uh it's what
my students want to use. So
I'm My interests are kind of guided by
what they want.
And then I have to put in a good word
for
uh possibly my favorite programming
language, which is Racket, uh which is
uh
uh uh
uh an evolution of Scheme, if you've
heard of the Scheme programming
language. So Racket is like a
high-powered batteries included Scheme,
and I strongly recommend checking it
out. It's really cool, and the community
is very friendly.
Uh all right. I hope that's a good
answer. Hm.
Yeah, and as far as this class, um so
Python's the most popular choice, and I
can understand why. Uh there are good
frameworks for Python uh for uh for um
doing the kind of programming that we
need to do for this class.
Uh
that's also the case for Go. Go has uh
Some people call Go the the the Python
of systems programming, and for good
reason. Uh
building things like uh a web service
is really straightforward in Go.
And
um
it and and often, you know, people
people like to
um
complain about Java,
but I think Java has a lot going for it
for doing things like this class
project. It has some some really good
APIs. So,
you know, I wouldn't totally discount
Java as an option, too.
Uh somebody just asked, they want to
know about my degree in music. Yes. So,
when I was an undergrad, I double
majored in music and computer science.
So, I went to a small liberal arts
college where it was relatively easy to
do such things. So, when I came in, I
didn't know what I wanted to study.
Um
I ended up being a music major at first,
and then um
kind of stumbled into CS when my
roommate took a CS course, and I
thought, well, I can do that, too. So, I
I took CS. It was a different time.
These days,
you um you can't stumble into CS as
easily just because there are so many
people trying to take it, that it's much
harder to even get into the classes.
So, but at the time, that wasn't the
case. So, I lucked out. I was in the
right place at the right time that I was
able to kind of stumble in and say, oh,
this looks cool, you know, I'll check it
out. That first course was taught in PLT
Scheme, which was the predecessor to
Racket, and I fell in love with it. One
thing led to another, I majored in CS,
and here we all are.
Um but I I studied music, also. Um so,
I'm a singer. Uh I don't play any
instrument particularly well. Um I've
got the like, you know, basic piano
skills that you might expect from a
music major, but nothing more than that.
I'm actually pretty bad. Um but I love
to sing, and in non-pandemic times, I
perform with the uh Symphony Silicon
Valley Chorale.
And uh
we haven't met for over a year, of
course, because singing is one of the
most unsafe things that you can do
during a pandemic like this, but um
uh actually, that's um segueing into the
the topic of the course. There are
software tools that make it easier for
groups to play music together remotely.
And um
uh
some of the members of our choir have
been taking advantage of that. For me,
um what it's really all about is
performing. So,
I don't get that much out of uh
going to rehearsal if I know that
there's not going to be a performance.
And so, I haven't been participating in
these uh
uh remote online uh rehearsals.
Um
but uh
it I mean, I I love to sing, I love to
perform. You can probably tell, right?
Like, I'm a teacher. Part of teaching is
performing.
And
um and actually, some of you, I guess,
have heard me sing because you saw the
um the PLDI video that that uh went
around. But um
uh yeah, uh
I
um
I I love to sing and uh I ended up being
fortunate enough to pursue a music
degree. Also, when I went to grad
school, I went to Indiana University,
which has a world-class music school.
So, there, I was lucky enough to get to
sing in a couple of really, really good
choirs.
And so, everybody else, almost everybody
else there was a music student. So, I
was like one of the three people in the
choir who wasn't a music student. And I
learned so much from getting to work
with those really world-class musicians.
Now, I wasn't nearly anywhere on their
level, I I should say. Or maybe I was at
first, but it would be like I was at the
level of maybe like the freshman music
students who were uh
who were there. And it was clear to see
how their skills improved over the the
year and a half that I was in the choir
with them, whereas my skills kind of
stayed where they were, right? Because I
wasn't putting in the hours and hours
and hours and hours every week of
practicing that they were. Um so,
like I was like just barely good enough
to be in the choir, whereas they were uh
like really taking off as musicians. So,
you know,
everybody has to choose where to put in
their time, their finite time on this
Earth. And
um I I chose to pursue other things. Um
but but I love to sing and um and I'm
fortunate enough to be okay at it. Oh,
what part do I sing? I I sing alto. Um
and how well can I sight read? Uh
I mean,
I it depends who you're comparing me to,
right? Like
uh
better than a lot of people in the choir
that I'm in now, but worse than a lot of
people in the choirs that I was in back
in Indiana. So,
uh
um
yeah, that's I guess it depends on what
what group you're comparing me to. Um
uh well enough to get by a lot of the
time.
When I I I will say it it also depends a
lot on the piece. So,
when I was uh
when I was in grad school, I somehow
ended up on this mailing list for people
who wanted to be in these kind of
experimental one-off choirs for people
who were composition students who needed
uh uh, musicians to perform the pieces
that they were writing. So,
I ended up in a couple of these concerts
where the composition students basically
just needed to get people together who,
um,
were able to perform these pieces on
relatively short notice. And also,
the the pieces were changing, right?
Like they would hear us uh, rehearse,
and then they would decide that they
needed to make changes, and they would
go back and edit the piece and then give
us something new the next week. So, that
was really tough. That was a big
challenge for me, and I had to work
really hard. And what I found was that
No, I had to work really hard. I had to
be very alert. I couldn't slack off.
And I found that when I brought that
level of alertness and skill back to
the the other choir that I was in, where
we were singing stuff that was, you
know, written 200 years ago, then,
um,
I was I was much better, right? But, um,
but still, um,
I I I would I I still wouldn't say that
my skills were anywhere near the level
of the the the more dedicated music
students. So, um,
it Yeah, I mean, I
I
I I
I I think it just depends a lot on who
you're comparing to.
Somebody has to anything that I've done
that combined music and CS? Hm.
You know,
I studied electronic music a little bit,
um, when I was in school, and so that
was kind of interesting. Like, one of
the things that we did was, um,
we studied some tools, some software
tools for making electronic music, some
of which, uh,
end up being Turing-complete programming
languages. So, some of these tools are
really, really cool. Um, I never really
did anything with that. I have been told
that the way that I think about music
uh
is the way that a computer scientist
would think about music, but I I can't
really you know, I don't know how other
people think about music. I can't live
inside their head, so
I don't know what really what that
means. Um
but uh yeah, no, I mean I'm not there
there's so much cool work in the
intersection of music and CS, but I'm
not really the one doing that work. Um
I am going to say that
so if you're interested in things like
um
data representation and knowledge
representation
um studying
uh
music notation is really interesting. Um
especially because there are a lot of
ways to represent
uh
to represent music and those ways are
they they actually differ between
cultures and between time periods. So,
one of the things that I studied when I
was in college was
uh different uh
different systems for lute tablature.
So, the lute was of course, you know, a
medieval instrument and different
systems for writing music for the lute
developed in different uh different
places at different times.
And they had different these different
systems of of writing had different
properties, right? Like some of them
were more more concise than others. Um
some of them were uh
uh more verbose. And so, to me that kind
of clearly has an analogy to things like
programming languages, right? So
something that I think is is interesting
to study is
how do
how does the cultural context affect how
people choose to represent the data,
right? And I I think that we see that
kind of thing come up in programming
languages as well as in things like
music.
But I'm not a scholar of this sort of
thing. It's only just kind of an idle
observation that I'm making and there
are people who actually do study this
kind of thing for real. So, don't listen
to me. Listen to the people who actually
know what they're talking about.
Okay, different topic.
Okay, the question is what what tools or
frameworks exist for testing distributed
systems, especially complex network
conditions like partitions and high
latency. This is a fantastic question.
I'm really glad you asked. So,
like we've talked about in this class,
testing distributed systems is really
hard. And one thing that I've noticed,
right, is that sometimes, let's say on
assignment three,
somebody will
somebody in the group will run the the
provided test suite and they won't get
any errors.
Somebody else will run the test suite
and they will see a bug.
And then the students will come to me
and they'll be sad, right, because,
you know, one person's test passed, you
know, shouldn't everybody's tests be
passing?
So, what I would say is no, you
shouldn't be sad. You should be jumping
for joy because the bug was present for
everyone.
But there was only because this is the
same code that these different groups
are running. It's just that the bug was
only exposed for one person. So, what
would you rather do? You know, if
there's a bug, would you rather know
about it or not? I think you'd rather
know about it.
So,
but why is it that the bug was only
exposed for one
one person and not another? It's because
these bugs are only exposed if messages
get interleaved in just the right way
that the
and the timing of those messages happens
in just the right way on a particular
machine or set of machines that the bug
is revealed.
Hey, sorry about that. I'm back.
Uh Zoom just crashed for me.
Let me uh share my screen again.
Funny that that would happen today of
all days.
And funny that it would happen right
when I'm talking about testing
distributed systems, huh?
Okay, we're back.
You know, a funny thing about that. So,
I learned recently that um
that on Zoom
you can't have breakout rooms with more
than 50 people in them or something like
that. So, uh a colleague a colleague
found this out.
Oh, the Twitch stream is down, too?
Okay, let me fix that.
Hm.
Now, let me see.
Um OBS says I'm still streaming.
Let me see here. Sorry about the
technical difficulties. I guess if we
had to have technical difficulties on
any day, I guess I'm glad it was today.
Mhm.
Okay, folks are saying it's working now.
So, okay. So, the question had to do
with testing distributed systems and
what what tools do I recommend for it?
Well,
first of all, just generally
I hope that
uh
it's clear, now especially after taking
this course, that testing distributed
systems is hard. And the measly little
test scripts that we have been providing
are not even close to sufficient for
finding bugs. So,
so what do you do? Well, ideally, you
want something that will try to exercise
all of the possibilities, right? All of
the interleavings of messages, all of
the combinations of machines being up
and down. You want something that will
systematically test a distributed system
and ideally insert bugs, right? So, we
talked about this a little bit earlier
in the course. Um we talked about this
notion of chaos engineering, right?
Which is inserting bugs into a live
system.
Um and so yes, this does mean testing in
production.
And that's not necessarily a bad thing.
This is always Everyone always claims
that testing in production is bad, but
the thing about testing in production is
it means that you're um you're looking
at the real environment in which the
code runs.
Uh so there's a whole lot to say about
that, right? There's a whole That That
would be a whole course unto itself. Um
but um the the question was kind of
specifically about like what um
what what tools and techniques do I
recommend? Um so I I I would recommend
looking into a couple of things. Uh
there is an open-source framework called
Jepsen, which is for
finding bugs in distributed systems.
It's for um throwing a bunch of bad
things at a distributed system,
simulating things like network
partitions and so on, and seeing how a
system behaves under those bad
conditions.
Um
now,
I don't know how easy it is to use. Um
one of the one of the issues uh
with it is that uh it was it was kind of
developed by an individual for his own
use, and uh and so that he could um
you know, show the world uh what bugs he
was finding in the systems that he was
testing. But it's uh as as far as I
know, um,
it's
the he's not necessarily providing it as
like a supported product. Um, however,
it is open source and you can go and try
to use it if you want to.
Um, there's also stuff like what my
colleague Peter is doing on lineage
driven fault injection. So, this is all
like a recent area of research, but what
this is about is
So, if you are injecting faults into a
system to try to make them fail, one
important question is
what uh, what does it make sense to try
to test first? Because there's this huge
space of possibilities. And if you try
to consider every possible combination
of say message message omissions, then
you'll never get done because there's so
many possibilities to look at. So, what
the lineage driven fault injection work
tries to do is it tries to prune the
search
uh, by making the space of options that
you look at um, smaller. And it does
that by trying to pick the kinds of
faults that would be most likely to
expose a bug.
Uh, and the way that this works is
really cool and and you can go read
about it if you want to.
Um,
I would also suggest looking into
there's the kind of this whole world of
what's called observability tools. So,
we've talked about this a little bit and
um, I think this came up a little bit
during Cyrus's guest lecture, um, but
um,
the step one, you know, to making sure
that your system works is to actually
know what's happening with your system.
So,
you can't uh,
you you you you can't debug your system
if you don't know how it's behaving. So,
observability tools
are a kind of a
a suite of of
um, tools and al- also sort of an
engineering culture that goes with it
uh, that's all about um, understanding
what your systems are doing, how they're
actually behaving in production. And
there are a few tools that are the And
this is all like kind of a very like
doing this well is still um, you know,
uh, very much an emerging field. Um, so
I don't want to really like shill for
any particular tool, but I I just will
say that there's a lot of really cool
stuff going on in industry in this space
right now.
Um, so if you're interested in in
learning about, you know, how did how to
do this, how to do this right, you know,
search for distributed systems
observability and you'll probably find
some cool stuff. And, you know, maybe
some of you actually have
recommendations for, uh,
for tools that you like. I don't want to
personally advertise anyone.
Okay.
What else?
Okay, why did I choose to use pen and
paper and document camera? Okay, another
good question. Yeah, so
well I started doing this
you know, out of necessity last year. I
had to start teaching online on very
short notice. I didn't own a tablet and
I like to write on paper. So, back when
I was teaching in the classroom, I wrote
on the board. I didn't use slides and I
wanted to have something that was as
close as possible to that experience um
uh, when I was teaching remotely. So um,
I got a document camera. It was actually
recommended by my colleague Sesh who has
the same document camera and he uses it
in his classes, too. Some of you have
probably taken classes from, uh, from
him as well and maybe you've seen him
use his. He has much better handwriting
than I do.
Um so
and then you know, why did why do I do
this instead of something more
high-tech? Well,
uh first it was just because I didn't
own a tablet. And then it I started I
kept doing it because I like it. It's
fun.
Um and students react well to it. So
um
I I've I was excited to to learn that
document cameras are a possibility for
home use. I didn't even know that was
something you could buy
until March 2020.
And so now that I have one I really like
it a lot and I use it not just for
teaching, but you know, when I'm meeting
with my students and we're trying to
draw things on paper
to if we were in person we would be
standing at a whiteboard together, but
this is kind of the next best thing.
Yeah, so
I the document camera has some cool
features um
that I I usually don't use, but um
uh I could try to
to show them off right now.
So
um
So so like for example,
I could um
I could change the let's see.
I could change the exposure.
Yeah, I could do stuff like this.
Yeah, that actually didn't seem to
change anything. Oh yeah, there we go.
So that's a lot brighter. Maybe I should
have been doing that the whole time.
There's also these cool video filters.
So if you want like yellow and blue,
I don't know why you would want that,
but um but there you go.
Um,
there's also like sepia
in case uh you want like an old-timey
feel.
Um,
and there's some others here like black
and white.
Yeah, I don't know. I don't know if this
is good or if this is Is this
distracting or is this better?
So, yeah, for the most part I just stick
with the standard um
no filter.
Is there a dark mode? Hmm, well, there's
inverted color.
Not sure what's going on there.
Um,
I don't think there's a dark mode as
such. There's red on black.
It's kind of cool.
Yeah, so that's the document camera.
Oh, what are your opinions on types of
databases? Uh
like relational databases versus NoSQL
databases. So, okay, so um this is
interesting, right? So, this came up a
little bit when we were talking about
sharding. Um,
so when we read the Dynamo paper
uh and we learned about consistent
hashing as a way to shard,
it was very straightforward in the sense
that it was a it you only had one kind
of data, right? There were key-value
pairs. And those key-value pairs are
totally independent of one another. You
don't have anything like dependencies
between different key-value pairs.
There's not anything like what you have
in a relational database where you would
have different tables and you would have
integrity constraints between the tables
and so on. So, in a lot of ways that
very simple flat data model is great
because it makes it a lot easier to deal
with things like distributed consistency
and fault tolerance uh because
you can uh
because those key-value pairs are
independent um you don't have to worry
about things like um making sure that
the data in one table gets kept up to
date with another table that might be
changing and lock a table when another
table changes, that sort of stuff. So,
uh really with all of these tools it
depends how you use them. I think with a
relational database there's a lot more
room for problems.
On the other hand, those kinds of
problems that I'm talking about like
having to maintain those integrity
constraints and so on, those problems
only come up at large scale when you're
when you have so much data that you need
to distribute it anyway. So, no, step
one of you know, choosing what kind of
system to use is you know, do you really
need a distributed system? And this is
something that kind of hasn't come up so
much in this course, right? Because
this course is about distributed
systems. I assume if you're here then
you care about distributed systems. But,
you know, step one of distributed
systems is do you really need a
distributed system? And Joe Hellerstein
uh who's uh one of the kind of leading
lights of database and distributed
systems research says um
well, you know, do
your your first the first thing that you
try should always just be like put your
data in something like Postgres and keep
using that on a single machine until
further notice, basically. So, and you
may never outgrow that, right? And if
you never outgrow that then that's cause
for celebration cuz that's good enough
for a lot of situations. It's only to
the point where you end up dealing with
data on the scale of a of um
uh
something like Amazon, right? That
that's very much not good enough. And so
then
um you need to start thinking about
these other concerns of availability and
so forth. And it's at that point when
things like this flat data model um
become uh really helpful.
So then, with the flat data model,
what's really interesting is that then
people some sometimes try to like
retrofit the features of a relational
database onto that.
And so that gets kind of interesting,
too. So you get databases where people
are trying to impose that relational
data model onto this underlying system
that kind of wasn't designed for it.
Uh so um
And and that kind of brings a whole new
set of of design considerations that are
interesting. So if you notice, I'm kind
of not picking a side here
um because the answer is always it
depends on your assumptions and um
and it depends uh
on the the constraints of of the problem
that you're dealing with. So um So my
opinion, as with everything in this
course, is it depends.
I'm getting some private messages, so I
I wonder if people are asking questions
privately. Let me see here.
Oh, just uh
it doesn't look like anybody has any
questions that they want to ask publicly
right now.
Um okay.
So, um
yeah, what else?
Anyone have homework questions?
Oh, here we go. Do you have a favorite
distributed systems research paper?
Well, that's a great question. So, so
obviously in this class we picked the
MapReduce paper and the Dynamo paper
because those are kind of
standards of the literature
and they're very different from each
other.
So, I kind of pick them for that reason
because they let you see, you know, kind
of different parts of the spectrum of
distributed systems work.
Um and they're also they're I would say
that they're both kind of showing their
age a little bit, right? Like they're
they're both, you know, uh
15 years old at this point. Um but
they're classics.
But if you ask me like what papers I
really really like,
I would go even further back in the
past. So,
I I like the papers from the '80s and
'90s. You know, what can I say? Um when
I teach distributed systems to grad
students, a lot of it is dusty old
papers from the '80s and '90s. And so,
if you want to um you can go look at my
CSE 232 syllabus and see what we read.
Um and a lot of those are papers from
back before there was any such thing as
what we call today cloud computing,
right? So,
a lot of work on distributed systems in
those days um
it anticipated the sort of concerns that
we would have now with fault tolerance
and network partitions and so forth.
But at the time those were largely
theoretical concerns. The authors were
planning for a supposed future in which
those things might happen, right? Um but
they were interested in those things
kind of the they they weren't
necessarily
um having to solve those problems in
their real lives.
Um they were just interested in those
problems because they're independently
theoretically interesting.
So now today it's so cool to see how
those questions that people were asking
and answering back in the '80s and '90s
are relevant, deeply relevant to
everyday modern software engineering
practice. And so, you know, I like I
like these dusty old papers because I
think there's a lot of cool insight to
be found in them.
And um not everybody would teach a
course that way, right? So not not
everybody who's teaching grad
distributed systems courses is um is
reading these old papers or focusing on
these old papers, but that's what I like
to do. So I have to do me, and that's
what I do.
Okay, another question. What big
companies in distributed systems are
good to look out for and watch? One of
my friends is working for CockroachDB
this fall, and hearing about them was
what got me interested in the field.
Yeah, so that's a great question. Well,
I I I wouldn't um I wouldn't necessarily
put the CockroachDB in the category of a
big company.
Um and a lot of the cool work is
actually happening happening at
not-so-big companies also.
Um
So yeah, I think there's um
uh
It It's so once again, I'm loath to
endorse any particular company. Um
I a while back I asked for a collection
of job postings from uh
from people that I could share with my
class, and I still didn't do that. So I
still have been meaning to share this
collection of job postings with y'all.
Uh I just didn't manage to put it
together yet. Um so, you know, I'll try
to do that in the next couple days, I
guess.
But um
uh One of the reasons why I was
hesitating is that I don't really want
to endorse any particular company
because I can't say that they're
necessarily good places to work, right?
Uh I haven't necessarily worked there.
So, I can't personally speak from
experience. And, um,
even if I had, right? My experience
might not generalize.
So, um, it's I it's it's hard for me to
to endorse any particular company. I
will say, um,
so,
the
the big companies are going to have a
different scale of problems than than
anyone else. So, you know, the the um
uh, the Googles and Microsofts and
Netflixes and Amazons of the world are
going to be working at a scale that
that nobody else has. And so, those, um,
and so, working there will expose you to
a kind of problem that, um,
that that nobody else has. And so, a lot
of the work that gets done, right? Like,
the invention of the MapReduce
framework. You wouldn't need something
like MapReduce if you didn't have a
ridiculously huge quantity of data. And
in fact, you should not use something
like MapReduce unless you have a
ridiculously huge quantity of data. It
would be the wrong trade-off to make. If
you have just like a moderately large
amount of data,
don't use MapReduce, right?
Um, so,
the the reason why they invented things
like MapReduce is because they had so
much data that the problems that they
had
required them to develop new uh,
uh, new tools to to do it. Um, my
partner likes to say that Google is a
machine for turning AI problems into
systems problems. So, AI problems, like
search, right? Becomes a systems problem
when you're doing it at the scale of a
company like Google because there's just
so much data. And, uh,
solving systems problems rather than AI
problems at that point becomes the
So, that's really, really interesting to
me, right?
On the other hand,
there's only a small number of companies
where that's actually going to be the
case.
Now, for me, you know, where would I go
work if I wasn't
if I wasn't a professor? Well, like I
said, I'm interested in programming
languages, right? So,
I was lucky enough to get to to work at
Mozilla on Rust as an intern in the
early days of Rust. These days, I might
go somewhere where I could
I could work on the next emerging PL
thing. So, Microsoft Research is one
place to go for that.
Um
but honestly, um
you know, you can
you can find
uh
you don't know it's hard to predict
where the cool programming languages
innovation is going to come from. Um
Sadly,
a lot of the people who who were at
Mozilla developing things like Rust and
Servo are now gone.
Uh so,
you kind of have to grab those
opportunities when you get them. It was
like a once-in-a-lifetime experience for
me to get to work on that, and I don't
know if it's going to come back again.
Um
uh these days,
um
so, I'm excited by
by the
the work that's going on in kind of the
broader Rust ecosystem.
Uh so, one company
that's using Rust is Fastly, and they're
doing So, they're doing cool distributed
systems stuff with Rust.
Um so, certainly I would look into them
if you're interested in kind of using
modern programming languages to solve
interesting distributed systems
problems.
Um and I have some good friends who are
working there, too.
Um
yeah,
RIP Mozilla Research, right?
Um yeah, so and and then in terms of
like
where to work, where, you know,
who has a lot of data? Well, also it
depends on um
the kinds of problems that you want to
solve. So, something that uh some people
who've worked on um
things like payments have told me is
that that industry is interesting
because
um they deal with less data in terms of
the total volume of data, but every
single transaction is extremely
important.
So, that's a little bit different than
the um than the aesthetic of some of the
other work that we've looked at where
it's like things can fail, right? And
it's okay if they fail.
Um if you're working in something like,
you know, where where actual money is
changing hands,
um
it's uh the the tradeoffs are different.
And so, your infrastructure needs to be
designed differently.
Um honestly, also, if you're interested
in cool distributed systems problems,
um
the game industry. So,
I
I think that game devs have
incredibly creative ways of solving hard
problems, and those incredibly creative
ways of solving hard problems don't
always make it into the mainstream
software industry, sadly enough. So, um
and and they often have their own
vocabulary and their own um culture,
right? But, they're talking about the
same hard problems that are in
mainstream distributed system software
development. It's just that they have
their own culture and their own
vocabulary, and so there's there isn't
necessarily a lot of crossover. Uh but,
if you want to work on really cool hard
problems uh
that have, you know, really uh like
interesting uh human-computer
interaction aspects to them, too,
um I I think online gaming is is uh
is is an interesting place to look.
I was lucky enough to have some guest
speakers from Blizzard the first year
that I taught this course. Sadly, the
people that I knew at Blizzard are no
longer there. Um
otherwise I uh I would have liked to to
to invite them to talk about that stuff
again.
Um but that was really cool. It was
really cool to learn about what they do.
Other questions?
Okay. So, somebody asked a question
privately about um
Yeah, so um I mentioned at the beginning
of the quarter that I I I took like an
online evaluation uh for um for ADHD.
So, it wasn't an ADHD diagnosis. I want
to be clear. It was just um uh
just this uh informal uh
kind of questionnaire. Um but
the questionnaire showed that I had
moderate ADHD symptoms. So, that's kind
of interesting and I might want to look
into whether I do indeed have ADHD.
Um
the the the question was, how do you
cope with that? Well,
I mean
during a pandemic everything's harder,
right? And you know, there's some
question, right? Like, do I really have
ADHD or am I just trying to be a parent
of a toddler and an assistant professor
during a pandemic?
And so, I don't know the answer to that
question, right? Um
uh
I will say this.
I think that
there are a lot of people in our field
who have learning disabilities.
And I think that it's more common among
researchers in our field than you might
think.
So,
I think that having a learning
disability, and I can't
I again, I had I don't have a diagnosis,
so I can't speak necessarily, you know,
from experience, but I think that having
a learning disability
uh makes somebody really scrappy and
resilient, and that's a really important
skill in research because research is
largely about failing and failing and
failing and failing over and over again.
And being rejected over and over again.
So,
that resilientness and that tenacity,
that resilience and tenacity is the sort
of thing that will really serve you well
in a career in research. And so having
life experiences that make you resilient
and tenacious, whether it's having to
cope with a learning disability or
anything else, uh are the kind of things
that can actually make you good at at a
career in research.
Another private question is how much
money have people offered you for your
Twitter handle?
Uh
I don't think anybody's ever actually
offered me money. So, I have the the
handle Lindsey on Twitter. Um so, for a
long time I didn't really use my
Twitter, and so I would periodically get
messages from people saying, "Well,
you're not using it, so can I have it?"
And um
I would always say no. And then these
days I I do use it. So, um
uh nobody's asked me that recently. Um
but yeah, it's not for sale.
Oh, somebody wants to meet my daughter.
Uh well, I don't know. It's so she and
my partner are uh
probably in the other room playing video
games right now. So, if she decides to
wander in, then she can, but um
not going to force the issue.
Uh somebody else also wanted to know how
I met my partner.
Have you heard of LiveJournal?
So, LiveJournal was a pre-Facebook
social networking website. Uh you might
have seen it if you ever saw the movie
The Social Network,
uh where it featured as something that
uh college-age Mark Zuckerberg had used.
And that that
I The movie wasn't necessarily a
realistic depiction of actual events,
but the part about LiveJournal was.
Um so, I met my partner on LiveJournal
in 2003, 2004, or so, when we were both
college students.
Uh we were online friends for many
years, and then we did not we did not
actually meet in person until uh
um 2007.
And then um
uh we hit it off. Uh we uh
um uh
uh became close. And one thing led to
another, and then in 2011, we got
married. And we're about to celebrate 10
years of marriage later this year.
Okay, a question about the course.
Which topic in this course do you think
is the most difficult lecture on?
Like difficult for me or difficult for
you? I don't know how to answer this
question. So,
hm certainly some of the uh
some of the lectures have been um
I had to put in a lot of work and study
to be able to do it, right? So, for
example, um
teaching Paxos was something that I was
very nervous about before I uh
before I taught this course.
Uh
so, I had to put in a lot of effort uh
for developing the examples that I would
show and so on. Of course, now that I've
taught the course a few times, I I don't
really feel that way anymore. I'm not so
nervous about it.
I think that a lot of the stuff in this
class is is, you know, very deep and
subtle. I remember the first So, the
first year that I taught the course,
um
I remember feeling
uh like um
I I I
I had I sort of went through a phase
went through phases over these three
years, where in the first year I
thought, "Well, the assignments, the
stuff that's in the assignments kind of
follows directly from lecture."
And then in the second year teaching the
course, I thought, "Oh, no, the
assignments are really much more applied
and they're much harder, right? It's and
much harder to understand than the
lecture material." And now now I'm kind
of coming to this different conclusion,
where now I'm thinking, "Oh, well, the
assignments are
um are not as hard, because the
assignments you can sometimes kind of
figuring out by them just, you know,
hacking until you get it, but the
lecture material is harder. So,
um
I really go back and forth on whether um
like which part of the course is harder.
And I think it depends a lot on the
individual. I will say that
I mean, I find that people who
um
people who do well on the lecture
material seem to also usually do well
enough on the assignments.
Um and I what That's a little surprising
to me. Like I I I might I might expect I
I I wouldn't necessarily expect that to
be the case, because the I I might
expect some people to really, you know,
even if they didn't understand the
lecture material so well, I might expect
them to be able to kind of hack things
together and make it work on the
assignment anyway. But lately I've just
been thinking that no, to to to really
do the assignments well, you really do
have to understand the lecture material.
And so, that's actually a little bit of
a relief to me. It's like, "Okay, good.
Like this theoretical material that I
feel is important actually does matter.
You know, and so knowing that it does
matter is it's it's a little bit of a
relief, right? Like it's not something
that we only have to study, you know, it
it's not something that we only study
because it's beautiful
uh and you know, of of theoretical
interest, right? Of intellectual
interest, right? It's actually also very
practical. And so that's the kind of
thing that I've been saying on my
soapbox for years, but now I actually
believe it, too.
This year I felt like
so one thing that's kind of been
interesting for me over the last year is
that my students and I have been working
on this verified implementation of
causal broadcast. And
when you work on software verification,
it gives you a new angle on things.
So
it really makes you
forces you to deeply understand how your
code works, right? And why your code
works and confront that. So
I feel like I have a a much better
understanding of causal broadcast than I
did before. You might not think that
causal broadcast is too complicated,
right? Like it's an old idea, it's from
the '90s. You might think that it's
pretty well understood,
but my understanding of it has certainly
leveled up over the last year because of
having to do this verification work. And
my students are asking me really hard
questions that force me to confront the
things that I'm still uncertain about,
which is great. So
um the way that it in which I teach it
is sort of starting to evolve, too,
based on that better understanding. And
that makes me happy because I love to
learn. I want to keep getting better at
teaching. Uh that's why I'm in this
field. So um
you know, I hope that the way I teach
the course is going to continue to
evolve as my understanding of the topics
improve.
Okay, another uh
uh not-on-topic
question, which is
"What's your favorite game to play with
family and your favorite game to play
alone?"
It's a good question. So,
I would I never used to be much of a
gamer.
Um
I didn't really grow up playing video
games. I didn't We didn't have game
consoles at home when I was growing up.
Uh so, I only kind of got into it as an
adult.
And I've had to do a lot of catching up,
right? Because there's there's a lot
that I'm I'm not so good at. I'm still
probably never going to be good at games
that are that require
uh
a lot of twitch skill, right? I'm never
going to be good at fighting games. And
And by twitch, I mean not twitch.tv, I
mean like uh fast reaction time. So,
I'm never going to be good at at those
kinds of games because I'm not willing
to put in the kind of effort for, you
know, it's like if I was going to be
willing to devote a lot of time to, you
know, hours and hours a day to
um to something like uh
that to something that requires really
um fine motor control, right? Then I
would have I then I would be a lot
better at the piano than I am.
So,
I clearly wasn't willing to put that
time in to become a good pianist. So,
I'm also not willing to put in that time
to become good at something like
fighting games.
Um but, I'm a casual gamer, I suppose.
So, um I play a lot of games with my uh
3-year-old. Uh
we have been playing uh
Super Mario Galaxy, uh which is a fun uh
3D platformer from 2012. Um
uh
My partner and I just beat Untitled
Goose Game last night, uh which was fun
and really charming.
Um
I don't know that I have a favorite
game, right? Like I kind of like puzzle
games, but um
uh
I also like game I like games that have
a sense of humor.
Um so I really liked the Portal games
for that reason because they were puzzle
games that were hilarious and had a
great story. So, um I you know, it can't
just be a puzzle game, right? I didn't
There There needs to be a story for me
to
uh to to be into it.
Um
and I've been playing I played a lot of
um
There's another really cute easy
platformer that I played a lot of with
my daughter, uh which is called Yoshi's
Crafted World for the Switch. Um so, if
you want a really extremely cute easy
platformer, uh I think it's a underrated
game.
Uh how did I get into organizing Bang
Bang Con? Um so,
Bang Bang Con was the brainchild of a
group of people that I met when I was a
uh resident at the Recurse Center. So,
if you're not familiar with the Recurse
Center, I'll I'll I'll share their
website. So,
the Recurse Center is a
uh
a programming community
uh based in New York, well, currently
based online, but it's uh
it's kind of like a writer's retreat for
people who want to become better at
programming.
Um they've been around since 2012, I
think.
And um
so at some point, um they invited me to
come uh be part of of what was called
their residency program, uh where I got
to go and spend a few days hanging out
there and working with their, um,
I don't want to say students because
it's not a school,
um, working with Recurse Center. And
batchlings, yeah. So, um, the the
Recurse Center uh, groups of people who
go there are called batches, so
batchlings, I suppose. That's actually
how I, um, met Patrick and how I
eventually convinced him to come to UCSC
uh, because he was at the Recurse
Center. So, in addition to the retreat
that they have, um, which by the way is
free, um, they also have this wonderful
online community, uh, which is, um,
which anybody who's ever taken part in a
Recurse Center retreat is is welcome to
join. And it's now this, you know, very
vibrant community of thousands of
programmers, um, and people who are
interested in in computing,
um, from all around the world. And so,
um,
I it's the best
uh, computing-related community that I
know of. And it's how I met the the
people who founded Bang Bang Con with me
back in 2014. Um, and if you, uh, if you
look on YouTube, you can probably find
the, um, the video of how Bang Bang Con
came to be because we kind of give this
presentation on it at the end of Bang
Bang Con every year. But, um,
it it kind of started as a joke.
Um, one person uh, said that they they
they wished that they could come to that
the Recurse Center runs this thing
called, um, uh,
uh, Never Graduate Week every year,
which is kind of like their, uh,
reunion. Um, and, um,
uh, somebody was kind of lamenting the
fact that they couldn't come to Never
Graduate Week because they didn't have
an excuse to come. Like, they didn't
have something that they could, uh, tell
their employer that they needed the week
off for. So, um, somebody joked and this
was all happening on the like the
Recurse Center online community, which
by the way uses Zulip. Um, so somebody
said on Zulip, "Well, you should just
make up a fake conference and then
pretend to have a talk at the fake
conference and then go."
And then a group of us said, "Well, you
could actually organize a real
conference, you know, in that much
time."
And then one thing led to another and
this joke turned into a reality. And so,
here we are 8 years later, still
organizing conferences and it's turned
into something that's a very important
and meaningful to to us.
And
I very much, you know, for me,
um,
you know, the Recurse Center is very
much about this kind of spirit of of joy
and experimentation
and um,
and eclecticism
that I think also characterizes Bang
Bang Con. Um, but it's it's not just
about having fun. It's also about uh,
me truly wanting to subvert computing
culture to
uh, to help encourage this uh,
this aesthetic in which
uh, in which community matters
and in which it's not all about
utilitarianism.
So,
I don't really have a prepared speech on
this topic, but um,
if that sounds appealing to you, I would
encourage you to check out Bang Bang Con
and also check out the Recurse Center.
And I think that
that some of you would really really
enjoy it.
Um,
have I attended DockerCon? Uh, no, I
have not.
Uh, sorry to say.
Also some game recommendations happening
in chat. Thank you for those.
Um have I ever played escape rooms? No,
I have not. Um
I've done a couple puzzle hunt type
things uh back in the before times.
Uh but that's different.
Uh somebody complimented me on my on my
uh
singing voice. Thank you.
Oh, yes. I said I promised I was going
to share the story of the octopus.
So,
well, I I'm not sure that I know the
story accurately either. Um so,
at the Recurse Center where they use
Zulip,
um so, they were early adopters of Zulip
at RC. And uh they used it before it was
even called Zulip. And so, they kind of
developed their own culture of how they
use it. And I think there might even be
a blog post here uh on their blog about
the way in which they use it.
Um it might be old, actually. So, I I I
don't know if I'll be able to find it
right now. Um but
uh
actually, this is kind of cool. So, this
is about the um
um
the tools that they've built. So, they
have something called RC Together,
um which is a um
uh a tool that they've built for um
uh for remote collaboration.
Uh
but uh
and and this was kind of this came out
of uh having been been developed during
the pandemic. But of course, they've
been using Zulip since way before that.
So, um
somebody noticed that on Zulip this
octopus emoji
um
could kind of be used in this very cute
way where, you know, you could pretend
to be holding something up in the arms
of the octopus. So, I I hope this
website is still online. If I go to
octopus.holdings
Oh, no.
Apparently, octopus Oh, no, it's because
I misspelled octopus. Haha. Here we go.
Yeah. Oh, no.
Still doesn't work. Darn.
Okay.
I'll try again.
Uh okay, I'll try again in a minute.
Anyway, um this it Maybe maybe it will
work for some of you. So,
octopus.holdings
is the website. So, it's this very cute
thing where this octopus emoji appears
to be holding up another emoji that's
stacked on top of it. And so, for
whatever reason this got to be, you
know, kind of memetic in the in the
Recurse Center community where everybody
uses the octopus emoji for everything.
Um and then, um because RC was an early
adopter of Zulip, um
Zulip decided to um
to kind of make the octopus emoji
featured in their in their interface.
So, in Zulip, you know, when you have
the emoji picker, um
it's uh
it's showing um
like popular emoji right in the in the
first set of of of options, but um
that's not actually You might You might
hope that that would be like uh
you know, somehow uh
um procedurally generated, right? And
not just hard-coded. But, it turns out
that it actually is hard coded. Uh so
it's um so that's actually just what
everyone sees regardless of what um what
emojis are popular in a given Zulip
server.
Um but what happened is that because uh
they put the octopus in that set, then
other communities that were using Zulip
started using the octopus a whole lot.
And so now um this octopus thing seems
to have spread to other communities.
Uh let's try again.
Oh, it still doesn't work. I don't know
I don't know why. Uh so Patrick says it
works for him, but I'm not sure. Anyway,
so when
Okay.
Okay. All right. Anyway, when we started
uh Bang Bang Con West, which is the West
Coast edition of Bang Bang Con hosted at
UCSC, um we decided we had to use the
octopus uh both because it was this uh
kind of inside joke for Recurse Center
people, and also because um we wanted
something that would be in the spirit of
the West Coast and in the spirit of
Santa Cruz. And what better choice than
an octopus, which is part of public art
in Santa Cruz, and also you know, here
at UCSC, um one of the things that we're
known for is like the Ceph uh
distributed storage system, which is
also named after cephalopods.
So, you know, for me this octopus was
just a very nice inside joke, um and
it's also just very cute. So, we have
the octopus holding up the exclamation
points. Um
and that's our logo.
Um yeah, that's that's the story of the
octopus. It's it's not really too
exciting.
Oh, okay. Somebody points out that it's
actually
emoji.octopus.holdings.
Okay. Oh.
Apparently, I had it uh
Uh that didn't work. Maybe I can if I
can do something else here. Um
So, what uh
if if I put something after the slash
here
like here's
an octopus holding an octopus.
Um
I don't actually know the names of all
the emoji in the default set. So, what
else should I try?
Um
Is tada.
Actually, knife and fork. What's that?
That's kind of a cute one.
Uh cake.
Yeah, okay.
You get the idea.
Um so, it may not surprise you to learn
that this octopus holdings website was
made by
uh a member of the Recurse Center
community.
Um
And um
you know, whatever you put in the URL
here will be what the octopus is
holding.
Any other questions or should we wrap
up?
All right.
Before we end, I'm just going to look
back at Twitter to see what other bad
advice was recommended that I share with
you all.
Hm. Haha.
So, one person said tell uh tell the
class that we just discovered a way to
tell if a message will arrive. Uh
this is a joke about exactly once
delivery.
Of course.
Or perhaps a joke about reliable
delivery more generally.
Yeah, so the fork and knife one uh,
somebody suggests is a funny one.
Fork and
knife.
Yeah, it just lines up so perfectly,
right?
How can you not love that?
All right, well,
on that note,
um, we're probably about ready to wrap
up for the day. The questions have
stopped coming in. So, thanks to all of
you for asking so many good questions.
Um,
and thanks for the game recommendations
as well.
I want to thank all of you. I know this
was I know most of you are graduating.
Um,
this is probably not what you expected
your senior year of college to be like,
is it?
Um,
and uh,
you've had to deal with a lot this year.
Um,
so, I want to say thanks to all of you
uh, for being so accommodating
of this difficult situation this year,
uh, for over a year, um,
in fact. And it means a lot to me that
you've been willing to put in a lot of
work in this class,
and that you've asked so many great
questions. I also want to say something
not just to to students, but to our
amazing group of of um, course staff.
So,
all of our course staff are incredible.
Uh, I don't know if you've noticed,
um, but uh,
uh, there's a couple people who I want
to call out in particular. Um, so um
Uh, Patrick in particular has been
taking live lecture notes and sharing
them on Zulip everyday
uh during lecture, which
I didn't say he had to do, right? Um,
nobody said it was a requirement of the
job, um, but he did it anyway uh because
he's just that conscientious.
Um, and then the other person I want to
specifically mention is Arya who created
beautiful slides for all of the course
staff to use during tutoring sessions
and um
and office hours
uh about all of the assignments. And
this again was something that I didn't
say she had to do, um, but she did it
anyway because she wanted to.
Uh, so
you know, you can't like I
I try to find a good course staff every
year, but it's always, you know, you
you you you never know what to expect,
and I think I really lucked out with
this incredible group of of staff. So,
thanks to all of them uh for doing such
a great job and um
and offering so much help. By the way,
all of the all the course staff um all
the tutors are people who previously
took the course and did well. So, um
uh they're really good sources of
information, um and they're they're I
think they're just good people to know
generally. Um
uh they're just really nice people as
well.
Um, and then our TAs, our wonderful TAs
Patrick and Abhay, uh they're both
people who I knew and had worked with
before and who are incredibly
trustworthy and uh
uh and reliable, and there's really
nothing more that I could ask for. So,
um
yeah, so thanks to all the course staff
for being awesome.
Um, and and thanks again for all of you
for really for coping for this difficult
situation over the last year and making
the best of it. I'm sad that I didn't
get to meet most of you in person. Maybe
one or two of you I met in person cuz
you took CSE 30 from me so long ago. But
um
I didn't I haven't gotten to meet most
of you. So come back to visit uh later
on when you can.
I'd love it if some of you could come
back and visit my class cuz I hope to
keep teaching this class. By the way,
somebody there was a question that kind
of went by that I didn't really get a
chance to answer. Somebody asked
is it true that UCSC is going to stop
teaching this class? No, that's not true
at all. Um so it's not being offered in
the spring next year. Maybe that's what
you're referring to. So I am going to be
teaching it in the fall. Um it's not
going to be offered in the spring. Uh
why am I not teaching it in the spring?
Because uh I'm going to be teaching a
different course. Uh so
I
you know, I can't teach this course
every time. Um
and um
uh I'm going to be teaching uh
but but I expect to be teaching it, you
know, for a while, at least once per
year.
Um so I know that it's not perfect, you
know, like some students are unhappy
that it's only going to be offered in
the fall next year um because that
doesn't fit in well with the rest of
their schedule. So I you know, I'm
sorry.
I don't make those decisions.
But um
that's uh
the those are those are the constraints
that we're that we're working with. And
the real the the the core of the problem
here is that we do not have enough staff
to teach all of the systems courses, all
of the PL courses uh
that we want to teach. So really the
answer here is that we need to hire more
faculty and we're doing our best.
Um yeah, so
uh question is can you stop by if you're
vaccinated? Um well, so
yeah, I don't know when I'm going to be
on campus next.
Um, uh,
but, um,
hey, you know, all I I expect to be on
campus in the fall, uh, at the latest
because I'm supposed to be teaching in
person in the fall. Fingers crossed that
that actually happens.
Um,
but, uh,
uh, but yeah, I'd love it if people
stopped by.
Um, and maybe I can get some people
together. Something that I've done in
the past is have a panel of recent grads
who can talk about, um, you know, their
experiences working in industry. We
didn't manage to make that happen this
time, sadly. Uh, but, um,
uh, that's something that I would really
like to do in the future. So, if any of
you want to who are graduating want to
come back and be on that recent grads
panel, especially if you're working, uh,
in a job that, uh,
where where you're working with
distributed systems, uh, I'd love to
have you back. So, yeah, just email me.
I'm also going to be teaching graduate
distributed systems in the fall. So, if
anybody's interested in either taking
that course, like generally undergrads
who do well in this course are fully
capable of doing well in that course.
So, feel free to, um, to talk to me
about that if you're interested in
taking, um, uh, grad distributed systems
or just sitting in on it.
Um, or you could sit in on the in-person
version of this class in the fall, uh,
too, if you want to, just if you feel
like it.
I probably will not be teaching on
Twitch in the fall, uh, just because
I'll be back in the in-person classroom
and I think it might be a little too
hard to manage. Um,
yeah, if you're graduating, uh, I don't
know, right? Like I I So, you're welcome
to come back and visit. Um,
uh,
I will never turn alumni away.
Um,
uh,
so, and and I think most of you are
graduating. So, that that probably
applies to most of you.
Um but uh
I don't know that I can keep doing the
Twitch thing and also, you know, be
present enough for students in the
classroom. So,
uh that that might be hard to do.
Um but you're you're welcome to if if
you can visit in person at some point,
it'd be great to have you there.
Oh, somebody wants to know if they can
be on this uh
this um
uh recent grad grads panel if they're
not working in distributed systems. It's
still okay with me. Um so
I feel like, you know, our students are
perhaps most eager to hear from people
who are working in distributed systems,
but if that's not the case, that's still
okay. So,
yeah.
All right, last thing I want to say is
stay in touch.
Um
so
something that
I've noticed is that
sometimes people decide
years after graduating that they're
interested in um
in studying more and they decide they
want to come back to grad school.
But then
they start to have regrets about the
fact that they haven't stayed in touch
with their professors. Because one of
the things that you have to do when you
apply to grad school is get letters of
recommendation from people who know you
well and can speak to your your
potential for doing research. So,
it um if you haven't been in touch with
uh with your old professors, then, you
know, they might not remember you,
right? You know, even if you did well in
their classes and so on. Um if you if
you didn't like form a relationship with
them that you then maintained, right?
Then, when it comes time to write that
recommendation letter years later when
you decide, "Oh, wait, I actually want
to go to grad school." Um then, you
know, your letters are going to be a lot
worse, right? So, what you can do is
stay in touch, right? Professors love to
hear from students who are telling them,
you know, how they're using what they
learned out in the world, especially for
a course like this. It makes me so happy
to hear from people who
who say that what I'm teaching is
directly applicable to what they're
doing. So,
I really do want to hear from you. I
want to get emails from you.
I want to hear what you're up to. And
who knows? Like, maybe years later later
you'll decide that you want to study
distributed systems in grad school, and
then I'll be like well equipped to write
you a strong letter because you'll you
will have stayed in touch with me.
And and even if that never happens and
you decide that you never want to set
foot on a university campus again for as
long as you live,
which is a position I could understand,
then,
um,
you know, even then it's nice to stay in
touch and hear what you're doing. It
makes me really happy. So, please do
stay in touch.
All right, folks.
Um,
I want to see your faces.
Those of you who are
uh
uh not on camera right now.
Uh
Are you willing to show your face for 5
minutes?
Or even 5 seconds?
A few of you are. Yay!
Thank you.
Aw, that's really touching to me.
All right.
Everybody, good luck on the final.
Ask questions. The course staff is here
to help answer questions as you're as
you're looking at that document of um
of
study questions that I shared. Um so,
you know, we're around. Ask us
questions. We'll be on Zulip. Um
and uh
good luck on the final. Good luck
finishing up assignment four.
And um I wish you all the very best as,
you know, especially those of you who
are graduating. Um
and it it it it means a lot to me that
you've been such great participants in
this class. And and like I said, stay in
touch.
Bye.